here's zelenski himself yesterday at the
NATO Summit calling for more weapons the
NATO membership and a bunch more
I think for today three per Euro team
questions the first one is weapon
packages new weapon packages for
supporting our army on the battlefield
and that is one the second I think the
invitation to need to and
um
we want to be
on the same page with everybody with all
the understanding and for today what we
what we what we hear and understand that
we'll have this invitation when security
measures
will allow all right apologies for the
audio on that it was extremely low the
actual audio on the mic so we had to
bump it up so that's why there was some
crackling there so he wants more weapons
and he wants in on NATO so he wants to
extend the war and let's even giving him
the complete benefit of the doubt let's
just say this guy just wants to defend
his country there's nothing nefarious
going on there's no money laundering
there it has nothing to do with Biden
and the laptop and all of the stuff
let's just pretend all this is all on
the all on the up and up right it's like
does that mean we still have to give
this guy endless weapons and also enter
an international agreement that will
immediately drag us into World War III
and why is it that as Tucker pointed out
there's really just no voices in America
in Corporate America in mainstream
America that are giving a little pause
to this thing yeah I can talk about it a
little bit that way Tucker could and now
he's no longer on mainstream media guys
like Glenn Greenwald David sack there
are some people talking about it but we
certainly should at least be able to
talk about it but every time anyone says
that and I have no doubt the Media
Matters people or whoever that watch
this show they're waiting for me to say
something so they can see see you see
Reuben is a Russian stooge he loves that
Putin he loves Putin just because I'm
asking questions and I don't want to be
driven to World War III by the way to go
to war we need Congressional
authorization I know we don't do that
anymore right so when when Obama went to
war in Libya when we got rid of Gaddafi
and now Libya is a complete failed State
we didn't actually go to war he didn't
uh get Congressional authorization he
called it a kinetic military action
sounds like Xbox Connect but it was a
kinetic military action so they always
find ways we can drop bombs all over the
place but I think at some point if
you're endlessly funding a war if you're
giving guys billions of dollars to kill
other people at some point you're at War
[Music]
thank you